[Music]
foreign
here and welcome back to quarantine
content just a little entertainment for
you while we're all staying inside I'm
your host Marquez Brownlee and this
is a new product oh yeah
that's a new Apple product this is a
wild time to be alive and and also a
wild time to release a new product
there's no events and there's no stores
no lines just none of the typical Apple
hype there isn't even any stores really
like if you go to apple.com right now at
the top it says hey all our stores are
closed right now until further notice
but then right underneath it says hey
check out our new stuff we just unveiled
so there is a bunch of stuff that's new
but there are two main things you
probably saw me tweeting about them that
is the new iPad Pro and the new Macbook
Air so feel free to the thumbs up on
this video if you want me to cover both
of those things in MKBHD style but for
now what we have here is the new refresh
2020 MacBook Air so the air is Apple's
most popular laptop it's our most
popular Mac really and it has been for a
while this change is just a nice little
refresh it's a little update to bring it
up to speed with 2020. you remember the
changes from the 16-inch MacBook Pro
from a couple months ago that made it so
great that stuff that I was asking them
to also bring down to the 13-inch
MacBook Pro
well they brought some of that down to
the MacBook Air here first so to start
the new magic keyboard this was the the
big change we were all waiting for
getting rid of the butterfly switches
and moving back to scissor switches
which are more reliable have more travel
feel better to type on they're just
straight up better in every way it's
still backlit it's still the same size
and everything but now it's just miles
better to type on matter of fact I've
been using that 16 inch MacBook Pro a
lot over the past few weeks because of
the new keyboard and it's been excellent
so I guess just generally good to see
apple basically silently admitting Fault
by slowly removing butterfly switches
from the rest of their lineup and this
keyboard also has the separate Escape
key no touch bar on the MacBook Air of
course and then the touch ID fingerprint
reader is separated off in the corner
and still works really quickly to unlock
and wake up and sleep and the inverted T
arrow keys are also back everybody's
favorite the specs also got an update
now to Intel's 10th gen ships and Iris
Plus graphics it's a good performance
boost this the MacBook Air has never
been a Powerhouse and it still isn't but
it also never really has needed to be so
this is a good update to catch it up to
speed you can get a quad core chip in a
MacBook Air now for the first time and
the iris plus Graphics are saying they
can deliver up to 80 faster graphics
performance and in graphics intensive
applications this isn't a review I've
only had this thing for a couple hours
so I can only really just rely on
benchmarks for now but yeah the numbers
say good things and yes that means it
will also now support Pro display xdr
now I don't know how many people set up
include a MacBook Air and a pro display
xdr but hey if that's you now you're
covered they also went ahead and doubled
the base storage to 256 gigs now and you
can go up to two terabytes for the first
time on a MacBook Air which is nice and
uh you can also do 8 or 16 gigs of RAM
which puts it right on par with the
Samsung Galaxy s20 Ultra that's a weird
comparison but they're also now still
saying you'll get all day battery life
they say 11 hours of battery life by
their tests now of course like I said I
haven't had this long enough to really
test that but that's a good sign that
the claim hasn't changed too much it
still should get pretty good battery
life and that is pretty much the meat of
it like they really haven't changed when
you think about it that much about the
MacBook Air it's still the super thin
laptop lightweight machine we all know
still the same port situation but what
they have changed is the stuff that's at
the real core of it literally which is
the specs and the keyboard but it's not
a MacBook Pro after all so there are
some things that they didn't change to
this laptop so the big one is there's no
screen upgrade on this MacBook Air it's
the same size 13 inch 2560 by 1600
screen and the bezels are all still here
it's a pretty nice screen but it's not
the best screen possible uh no Wi-fi six
and still a pretty garbage quality 720p
not even 1080 webcam this is what that
looks like it's still kind of impressive
how bad the webcam is still look in
these MacBooks and then the microphone
it is improved and I think it sounds
pretty good there's a pretty low signal
noise ratio it's not exactly up to the
quality of the 16 inch MacBook Pro which
you might even want to record a podcast
on but decent array of improved mics in
the MacBook Pro it just it's still going
to look like this like this what you're
hearing now this is what a studio
quality microphone sounds like just in
case you're wondering uh anyway there's
better speakers in this laptop too
there's more bass and about 25 more
volume than the last MacBook Air
I will say they don't match up to the 16
inch MacBook Pros new speakers but
that's totally unfair because nothing
really does those are incredible and the
new Macbook Air speakers are actually
quite nice they get pretty loud and they
sound clear they're still not as Bassy
as something from a bigger laptop but
I'm impressed here then the final update
which is price this now starts at 9.99
which is still an expensive laptop but
that's pretty good especially when
you're competitive with other laptops in
this category with the same components
same performance and a pretty premium
design plus it's 100 bucks off if you
have a edu email address so it starts at
8.99 for them so that's your first look
at it my take is at the end of the day
barring any weird performance problems
or strange glitches that I haven't found
this is setting itself up to be again
Apple's most popular computer
for here on out and it makes me want to
switch my daily computer that I carry
most often as a laptop is the 13-inch
MacBook Pro
I still hate that keyboard it's still
the flat butterfly switches and uh I
feel like I could easily switch to the
MacBook Air I don't do anything that
complex I don't do video editing on my
laptop that much so this could easily be
my daily if I can get used to two ports
I think the number one thing I would
miss is the X reports and a little bit
of a brighter screen but generally
MacBook Air is looking pretty good
either way this refresh is about what
we're looking for for the MacBook Air
good work now Apple if you could get on
it with the 13-inch MacBook Pro that
would be nice either way that's been it
thank you for watching let me know if
you want to see some iPad stuff and
leave a comment below what do you guys
think catch you guys in the next one
peace